i'll tell you what i know about history
man y'all don't know about history bro
brendan doesn't know about history dude
dude i don't you definitely don't man
bro you don't know about history dude
name something from history dude you
name something name some name a history
book your mom read to you when you're
homeschooled the alamo
[Music]
back off my broccolini
[Music]
is that a gucci top from the north pole
this is balenciage baby damn daddy
yeah uh that's that fan francis
this macron or something francis macron
or whatever damn looking fly out there
in nashville man
frank yeah it's rob ford baby you know
said nice [ __ ] damn
santa got paid this year daddy
well i don't know i mean it's definitely
a loan or one of the arms itches in it
oh it looks like it oh where's it been
the sled got some spinners on it or what
i'm afraid to reach in there i think
this was cat williams at some point
heavy on the cat bro cause this thing's
dandered up boy if you look down one of
these things boy you can hear a meow
every now and then i'm allergic to them
[ __ ] so [ __ ] them cats you're looking
where's that where's that little sesame
cinnamon stick you got over there where
is he at oh you're talking about that
little [ __ ]
egg roll you talking about stevie dude
he went to the strip club without the
cat's crew and i think he got pink eye
from somebody farting his face yeah he
was he had his nose in somebody's
butthole for sure who gets pink guy at
his age look at him who gets pink guy at
his age
so first of all somehow i can't come in
today guys they got pink guy you notice
how steve has no under eye like there's
no definition
it's just it's just i it's just cheek
and i are like combined
look asian person saying they got pink
guy that's the dog ate my homework of
white kids okay so facts
facts
do we really think that pink guy just
didn't feel like doing the christmas
episode maybe he forgot a gift
i forgot a gift
oh no he said dude there's pus coming on
man i feel horrible dude what the [ __ ]
it could be actually puss if he was at
the strip club yeah i asked him if he
wanted to zoom in and he was he was not
happy he was offended
of course he's offended he's offended
god you don't have aids stevie it's
[ __ ] pink guy dude yeah he said it
was an offense to his dynasty i'm like
you don't have a dynasty dude it's
you and bob yeah it's a very soft
dynasty he is i mean i don't want to be
like the stereotype or anything but like
i can't see the pink eye
you know
i'm with you too i'm with no i'm with
eric a little bit on this it just looks
like he's been crying it just looks like
his regular eye yeah
maybe more asians have pink eye than we
know
his car insurance rate went up you know
what i'm saying
it's like if the three of us say hey man
these allergies are popping we all got
noses on us you know what i'm saying
something so that yeah makes sense thank
you a lot of asian a lot of asian folks
uh also
they um here we go
we tried getting past it this is called
this this is called the racist rev-up go
ahead theo
come on man it's called circling back
around racism
i'll tell you what i don't know about
history man y'all don't know about
history bro brendan doesn't know about
history dude dude i don't you definitely
don't man
bro you don't know about history dude
name something from history dude you
name something name some name a history
book your mom read to you when you're
homeschooled the alamo
i don't know much about this history
no one's inviting the three of us to a
cocaine party with these noses yeah well
i wouldn't do cocaine anyway dude look i
saw a gal one time in asia eating bird
feet the talons not even grilled or
nothing just straight oh like i mean
fresh off the
farm-to-table type of thing oh
yeah this was flock to table this thing
had been
this is sky to table sky to table lock
the table oh i think this thing had
that's not like a good asian restaurant
flocks
dude i saw her open a bag on a train and
just eat the talons on the train man and
then she spit their little fingernails
or whatever in her head oh my god
i thought it was pretty hot oh yeah you
turned on by it
not turned on but not turned off you
know at least
you appreciated it
but china a lot of koreans and different
people
like that have uh
they they're they're not afraid to eat
stuff like we are here in america i mean
fear factor is basically lunch over
there
i gotta be honest though man brendan
knows i eat like i love eating kind of
organs all kinds of yeah all kinds of
crazy stuff even blood coagulated blood
yeah that makes sense yeah but then
liver but then asians can have like milk
yeah we're like most of us are lactose
intolerant we can have cheese but i
still eat it all the time oh you eat
cheese chicken oh yeah stickiest one
that's your [ __ ] this is one i like the
most no
i'm good and what's a what's a harsh
cheese on an asian
ah a harsh cheese maybe a havarti
oh
check out the big brain on chad
maybe we are fancy you just oh
love cheese man we're like fat mice dude
we love us some cheese
what's going on for christmas out in
asheville dale you staying out there
you're going to see the family in uh new
orleans i'm going back to louisiana
brother that's what i'm doing man merry
christmas to you guys over there man i
wish i wish i was over there with you
and
i'm just glad that uh i get to be here
with today and we all get to be together
man i'm going to louisiana what are you
guys going to do i'm looking for my
christmas bonus uh
envelope where's that
oh this is like uh christmas vacation
yeah that's a great question man where
is this christmas like i'm looking and i
don't see the
[Laughter]
oh i'm sure it's up there somewhere
what are you doing for christmas eric
i'm just hanging out here with rachel
and i'm just running and even answered
friends didn't even comment he just said
what you doing here
just moving past the bonuses yeah yeah
i know this is like mom and dad and you
know they didn't get their check this
year so there's no presents under the
tree that's these two
man we didn't even
be the worst gay dads ever at christmas
that would be awesome man
what we we all well i'm not being a gay
dad yeah you are yeah you are you'd be
one you would be my gay dad man yeah my
gay soul mate you and you would be a
great coach
he would keep trying that he would like
keep trying to adopt kids but they would
keep giving him ethnic ones so he would
just keep going and going and going
until you got it they're like this is
the ninth one it's just not working out
it's like yeah do you have any white
kids
but he wouldn't say it like that do you
have any ones that are saying
not so tan yeah
what is this yeah you got an eggnog
oh i don't if something a little more
nordic okay i'm gonna say i don't do
eggnog eggnog i don't do it either but
i'm doing it
it's super thick yeah cheers boys cheers
because i don't drink it you didn't put
alcohol in this didn't you no no it's
just oh it tastes really delicious how
you don't do eggnog eric but you look
like you do eggnog
really
say you drink eggnog without saying you
drink eggnog
that's harrod
it's kind of racist huh yeah a little
bit
you have too many whiskey eggnog
that nog starts turning a little theo
makes anywhere with n and g in it racist
oh
that's not true
damn even how he said that i went ooh i
don't like how he said
a [ __ ] fruitcake this year maybe yeah
maybe a little fruitcake
dude is there a bigger fruitcake than
you son
i don't think so baby fruit at the
bottom fruit at the top
in the middle doug oh bro this little
cup of broguard over here is the damn
freaking fruitiest thing i've ever seen
baby
let's take a little break with the
shenanigans the christmas shenanigans
with the cat's crew because guess what
man
you know it's winter dude and a lot of
y'all getting sick out there and the
cold is popping your boy had a cold and
thank god i beat this
flu season or whatever it is because
listen i'm all athletic greens up that's
right the health and wellness company
that makes comprehensive daily nutrition
really really simple all right they got
you covered man ag-1 by athletic greens
the category leading superfood product
all right they have comprehensive and
convenient daily nutrient for everybody
all right one tasty scoop of ag-1
contains 75 vitamins minerals and whole
food source ingredients including a
multivitamin multimineral probiotic
green superfood blend and it's delicious
listen it's tough to fill in the gaps
your diet but ag-1 does this for you man
and it tastes fantastic and it's a
powder no pills none of that stuff all
right join the movement athletes comics
moms dads rookies first timers
podcasters we're all doing it man you
need this to make it easy athletic
greens is going to give you an immune
supporting free one year supply of
vitamin d and five free travel packs
with your first purchase if you visit
athleticgreens.com cats today again all
you got to do go to athleticgreens.com
kats to take control of your health and
give aj1 a try
listen this holiday season give yourself
the gift of some delicious food whatever
it is man for the family for yourself
grubhub is the perfect gift for everyone
on your list including yourself
guaranteed all right this holiday season
give the gift of grubhub people will
love it whatever food you're looking for
get delivered to the crib family friends
holiday party grubhub does it all
grubhub gift cards are the perfect gift
for everyone on your list guaranteed
what do we got nick uh so we got a lot
of christmas related submissions today
and it makes sense and we're doing white
elephant at the end but this guy has a
question about jake paul tyrone woodley
damn daddy is sweating in this [ __ ] i
told you you were going to be honest
that's so hot i'm doing
something off you already got a [ __ ]
sweater on i'm doing it for the game
y'all stripping
what is up king and the steam crew it's
andre from oklahoma here excuse my voice
these allergies in the midwest are
kicking my butt
but
everyone in the studio if you watched it
if you didn't watch it and just seen
clips i just wanted to get to y'all's
thoughts on this
jake the problem child paul versus tyron
the chosen one woodley ii fight
if you've seen it
jake paul
i mean
put tyron willie to sleep with 50
seconds left in the sixth round which is
crazy because even being a jake paul fan
i had tyrone woodley winning at that
point
but
if y'all watch it i just want to get
jaws views and thoughts on it
and
hey have a great day hope y'all are
gonna have a merry christmas
thank you little red riding hood
um i have a question all right so i'm
not i'm not a fight aficionado or
nothing like that you guys know i don't
like this kind of stuff but i did see
that violent thing you saw you saw the
clip i saw the clip and i was like wow
but let me ask you this yeah
who is
is canelo like a the premier boxer right
now best in the world
number one all right
so if you're a fighter
would you take a fight with canelo with
two weeks notice absolutely not right
and why is that
because the level he's at i mean
his last fight a guy did do it on i
think a three-week notice and he also
talked about a guy who's been boxing
since he was eight i know but what i'm
saying though is that what i'm saying is
no pedophilia though sorry guys
trying to give him the facts you know i
know what i'm saying is like it's a to
me
it's a lack of respect for like to think
that yeah i'm just gonna take this fight
within two weeks well hold up
whitley was training he thought tommy
fury was gonna pull out so he's been
training it wasn't like well that makes
sense
that makes it even worse because to me
i think it's time
for jake paul to fight a real boxer
because he's going to really hurt
somebody define real boxers i'm saying
somebody that's like cause this guy that
he fought wasn't necessarily a boxer
right was he talking about a hall of
fame
uh ufc fighter i know but isn't bach
just because you're good at ufc doesn't
mean that is it you'll see a combination
of all that stuff it's different but at
the same time too like
so he was supposed to fight tommy fury
right who's supposedly a quote-unquote
boxer tommy fury is an easier fight than
woodley for him you think so i don't
know it didn't look
to me
my ignorance my my naivete about this
it looked like
that dude was not ready to be in the
ring with him
yeah like because like you know anybody
does this right anybody can get caught
at any particular time right anybody no
matter who you are and i just i don't
know if that guy had the the it didn't
seem like he had the techniques
to like protect himself i mean he could
have killed him man he could have got
him look that was a vicious ass hit man
vicious they dr first of all they
dressed up little tyrone as a you know
they dress him up like a damn little
christmas ornament out there like a
little uh
christmas ornament at something you'd
buy at like a gay gas station like a
little santa thought come a little santa
thought i mean whoever dressed him right
you know
gas station
is it called 69
phillips 69 bro
so you know they dressed him up out the
gate you know they had him looking a
little christopher robin out there out
the gate
then
you know good and well brendan that
tyron woodley has not been the same guy
for the past three years i don't think
he's not he doesn't want to fight his
last six fights he didn't say this out
of total respect he was oh and four in
his last four fights in ufc i don't
think he is mentally in the same place
that he was spot on so it's almost like
beating on somebody that is not mentally
well that's what i personally felt like
i don't see i wouldn't say mentally well
i think it's like beating on somebody
who is just doing it for the payday
like you know what i'm saying like he's
not doing the same things that got him
to the world championship level well
that's what i'm saying though he didn't
look like he he was ready for the fight
and i just feel like i think that jake
paul at at this point and now it's like
you need to fight hold be a be fight
like a guy that's boxing here's the
thing though all the hate on jake paul
and stuff no this is no happening no no
i don't know i get it everyone's i'll
fight a real box like that go go to any
whoever name a box that you guys like
tyson fury
mike tyson evander holyfield any mexican
dude sure julio chavez senior junior
whoever the [ __ ] you want canelo their
first four fights they were fighting
cans that's how it should be i know jake
paul's first four fights are way more
difficult than anything your favorite
boxer fought well you have to give the
guy credit at some point he also had in
his contract you can't knock me out so
no that's not true
that's not real
good that's been debunked
yeah i was jealous of the rest that
tyron woodley got i mean you saw him go
to i mean i i you can't even get sleep
like that anymore as an adult five
minutes
yeah that was like oh dawg i was like
damn that wrapped me up in a hampton inn
son let's do this boy yeah we can figure
that out
you come out here with the [ __ ] you give
me i'll i'll give you a quick nap
brother if that's what you're looking
for
dude
that's bad look at the raft too the ref
is like oof yeah the ref's like this
yeah yeah we got the rest of the emotion
like oh this is done
yeah but listen you do that to woodley
like now to your point like you want to
see him fight a real fighter quote on
quote boxer you're gonna get it you
flatline woodley are you gonna get it
okay here's let me ask you this though
let me
you just remind me both of y'all theo
everybody in here that's into the
fighting all right so let's say he wants
to fight canelo who is like the chain
not happening oh go but listen okay this
is my whole point
it is a lose lose for canelo 100 all
right and it's a win for jake no matter
what right because like even if he just
getting in the ring well that's logan
paul floyd mayweather no but but that's
different because
floyd is he already retired and he
already did that other ridiculous fight
with the other guy that he could have
demolished but he for the money he let
it go you know you know what i mean
george orwell or whatever no no the uh
conor mcgregor conor mcgregor he could
have he could have killed conor mcgregor
in the ring and he just let him like he
made it he made it entertaining that was
wwf yeah okay but what i'm saying is for
like canelo can only win if he does this
if if as soon as jake paul gets in the
ring he has to demolish him in a way
that
hey man this levels to this canelo would
never do it he makes too much money
but put on but what i'm saying though is
like it's like
i was center in seventh grade and i had
to face a female nose tackle it was a
lose lose for me yes even though she
should be drastic no no i shut her down
no
she was she was about twice my size and
i cut blocker the whole time but she
didn't get any tackle no but but it
wasn't it wouldn't be stuck
on top of me every time all right all
right jeff saturday but it would be like
a um it would be like a social
influencer starting to do comedy and
then he's now co-headlining with
chappelle yeah yeah yeah yeah you know
what i mean and then yeah there'll be a
victory even if you're ready or not
you'll be like i did it i worked my way
and i got this guy unless you get
knocked out in 30 seconds
the paul's the pauls have put themselves
in a great position yeah you know a
great business position it's a great
business move it was before the holiday
people are sit and people are curious
people want to you know entertain
woodley's just doesn't let go with the
hands he just it's not his universe
and uh without that man
but bethea does that imply then that
he's not
proficient in boxing enough to agree yes
somebody that like no he's only four
he's only 4-0 though so his people
don't fight like canelo and [ __ ] i'm
saying woodley is not proficient in
boxing
yeah that's my question
it looked as if like it looked as if
like that guy because even that move
that what whatever he did to make him
yeah whatever he did the dude almost was
like okay then he just went like take my
face and i was like goddamn you see that
in slow-mo you got paige though and
that's what some people think it was he
took a fall some people that's not you
too
some people
they're stupid
you don't know i know for a fact i know
woodley very well trust me he did not
take a fall as your boy dustin poirier
if woodley took a fall he he's really
close to woodley anybody knows woodley
trust me but why would he ain't saying
hey i'll take a fall you can flatline me
in the front why would he say that and
ruin my career and now the chance for
him getting signed anywhere else is not
good it's so i want to see him
how much did he get millions probably
millions millions
and jake actually gave him jake because
of the rumors of the whole five hundred
thousand dollars gold stretcher
jake actually put in the contract that
tyler woodley if tyronn really could
knock him out if not jake out he would
give him 500 000 extra that was actually
in their contract
these boys playing with some loot yeah i
wish it was i wish it was all or nothing
you know i wish it was like let's say
the the thing is like a 50 million
dollar thing you would go in 50. you
know you say you're gonna get like 10 to
pay your fees and all your people you
get that but it's like imagine if the
fight was like you get you know um if
it's 50 million you get 47 million if
you win and the other person gets three
i think they these [ __ ] were
fighting
ufc is kind of like that ufc is kind of
like that yeah but it's not the same
amount of money though right
at the higher levels it is oh wow yeah i
think look man these guys did it they
put the show on again it's a great show
to see it you know and it's yeah i'm
excited to see what's next
well he said le'veon bell they said
le'veon bell last night now no do all
i'm saying is
listen i'm saying this they need to put
some respect on jake paul's name
yeah that's my point i don't know that's
what i'm saying like you know you i
don't was he really training like you
take the fight like come on man i think
it's like like even if
to me it's like if if i'm gonna fight
say canelo you you're gonna need six
months like what's a what's a a proper
training a camp
eight weeks of proper training but you
know what what's that's that term they
always say styles make fights correct
right so
what about tyrone woodley style
made him think that oh i'ma go i can
hang in the ring with jake because jake
has no experience and woodley has a ton
of experience in the ufc that's what
they were thinking and where they
knocked out plenty of people yeah
do you have the good news i don't like
that but again i don't like that
comparison i don't think i don't think
boxing and ufc need they need to stop
comparing the two it needs that needs to
end because it's not the same
yeah but i think it's just these two
it's an interesting thing you're like
this guy has a lot of fighting
experience it's just guys
what's that i said you're right
sorry you're right though yeah it's just
enough there's enough curiosity there
but i think the curiosity is it might
start wearing off or
he might just continue to beat uh
urban men from different sports which is
what he's doing
you see you see the love
y'all need to get a real brother or get
a freaking vato in there dawg i think
dude i know nine dudes that work at a
car wash in tucson that'll freaking
definitely go 12 rounds they got some
hands giving them hands you tell me you
boys want to watch jake paul versus nate
diaz jake paul versus conor mcgregor
jake paul versus anderson silva now i'd
watch all of those yep we'd all paid for
it all right what else you got nick uh
this guy's got a king of their sting it
for us but i think jake paul would knock
mcgregor out oh wow
wow
wow hard take by eric yeah he's a lot
big man see like i'm fascinated if that
happens yeah i think he he if he caught
him if you know connor's hundred ninety
pounds i'll 100 steal that fight if that
happens
i mean i'm surprised blm ain't getting
that jake paul for some of this [ __ ]
behind the christmas tree
considering it's christmas time i got a
king understanding for you
office slash work christmas parties
i know i would never be caught dead
there you got the manager always getting
sleazy with the ladies
co-workers getting drunk and sloppy
talking some
[Music]
oh so cute oh she's cute yeah i think
he's referring to that that cop right
he's a chief police and then what what
cop is bodied up like this one given lab
dances well what are we talking about
here can you see it deal that so this uh
nypd rookie gives lieutenant lap dance
at wild holiday party now under
investigation
i'll tell you what's wrong with this
what's up
look at her she has some experience in
the field
okay she's a cop can i yeah that's a cop
doug wow let's finish watching eric and
you should get your boy
lock me up you feel it lock me up
yeah that is crazy she's a cop that's
crazy
this precinct is lit family hell yeah
that's new york so they can't arrest
people right now that should be the new
strip club in new york
3669. hell yeah
look this uh go on eric you were leading
the charge here what you got
not everything should be on the internet
like i have i have zero problem with
this like absolutely zero problems oh
that's you're saying yeah i'm zero zero
zero zero they're at a holiday party
they're with they know each other
everybody's friends so what did this
chick hot chick is a cop and she wants
to like you know have some fun at a
holiday party and then some idiot
videotaped this and then and they put it
out on the internet and now we're
shaming her and making this guy out to
be a pervert well he he's gonna leave
let me please leave now i know but i
know and this is my problem with it is
stop putting [ __ ] on the internet
okay keep your life to yourself nobody
gives a [ __ ] about you stop it yeah all
it's gonna do is hurt this guy so if
you're cops why are there cell phones
out at this holiday party also look at
his wife can't blame him for getting a
lab dance what that's his wife that's
his wife and she was actually pissed at
the press she was uh they were like
trying to go back to the house and ask
her questions she was like [ __ ] you [ __ ]
you isn't there more stuff to be worried
about yeah she's right man i'm saying so
she looks like honey boo boo whoever the
rat is look whoever the rat is at this
party it's that's why when you have like
even even take it to this level like in
comedy shows that's why we started to do
that thing where it's like put your cell
phone in a bag
just can we just live life that we
experience this without it but out of
being like well i have to record this
be present and now out of context i have
to do this yeah i think this is terrible
i don't have no problem with her good
for you she fine and a cop good for her
and and they and she was just doing her
thing at a party that she didn't think
this was gonna get you know put out on
the internet like this this sucks that
girl got skills it sucks
okay hold on fellas what i'm saying is
this man
when you defund the police bro you start
getting some real second third stringers
in there you get strippers now we're
cops you get an i.t guy as a cop
you get a fisherman in there he trying
to catch a criminal on a damn uh
chicken liver or spinner bait you know
what i'm saying you get all type of you
getting some real different anglers in
there so this lady obviously is a sexual
worker or a dancer in a past life or at
some time sexual being but
now we defund the police they're letting
anybody just like when the nfl was on
strike and everybody's daddy was out
there playing for the uh oilers it's
called the replacements
yeah it's just like that man so that's
who you're getting you getting the i.t
guy he's out here you know he's so i
think you have a lot of people that
aren't used to being cops um
and then also you got the surveillance
department at the party dog they doing
their job son that's all they doing baby
haters they do it
wasn't worth it that's all i said also
like you feeling that putting it out
what the [ __ ] are you doing yeah was
that worth crazy was it worth it like is
the person that filmed that what did
they get out of this
no it's not even like the did they sell
it did they did it i need to know that
they made money off that video well
that's why if you go to like celebrity
parties even if it's just like a dinner
or a kids birthday party they take your
phone you're like you believe they're
doing something like yeah
me too because you're gonna put it on
the internet i just went to i just went
to a like a celebrity type christmas
party and it was like you had to leave
you had to check your phone in and i
totally got it my girl was furious
because she was like i want to take
pictures no they're saying that you know
and i was like nah you know it is what
it is and it's like it to me it's a
shame that people can't be present and
just live your life without having to
share it then and then now out of
context somebody's life is real he lost
his or he's on paid leave and this is
messed up but also what they should do
is they should tell who put the video
out right yeah the person i'm sick of
people being able to put videos out and
there's no responsibility
for the videographer you know
larry ellwood or whatever did this video
that way yeah that was a blast
before you put a video out
you have to know okay am i willing to
co-sign on this yeah everybody knowing
that i'm the blaster because if i get a
whistleblower yeah if i'm a cop in that
station i'm not trusting that dude who
blasted it out he should lose his job we
can't trust the snitch and yeah
drive fast by her
army over girl i'm a nick on this lock
me up girl i don't know why they're
blurring her face she's she's i know
you're killing it and this one eating
nick no i don't know if speeding would
be next crime i think what would next
nick's more of a peeping tom type of
vibe i agree learn from the best boss
[Laughter]
you can't sleep here
nick showing up with a white elephant
gift out of somebody's
outside of somebody's bedroom window
yeah nick's gonna get arrested for like
loitering or so i'm shooting somebody's
hot tub but then i have the gift in my
hand like no yeah yeah that's true yeah
what's this little let's get to this uh
she's got a king at her sting it for us
hey guys long time listener first time
caller my name is alyssa and i have a
king it or sting it for you holiday road
trips with your dog your little furry
companion that's penelope she has been
on a number of road trips with me from
california to north carolina and texas
and now back up to iowa again uh to
visit family for the holidays so king
understand it road chips with your dog
also um i've been waiting to see theo in
san antonio or austin for a long time
now i saw brennan a couple years ago and
i've been waiting to see fio my favorite
comedian that netflix special was
awesome loved it can't wait to see you
live hopefully someday soon but you keep
going ontario and other crazy places up
north yeah i'm not interested it's a
rainbow that's great we won't bite
thanks guys happy holidays
oh there's where my christmas bonus went
yeah
yeah we paid her 59 though hey
hard king it sounds like she needs a
companion road companion you feel me
yeah if you're looking for a thick ass
elf jump to that california trip you let
me know girl yeah that the dogs on trips
sting it could you don't want to see
your dumb ass dog
well she might be
that's a road trip companion man yeah
yeah get theo in the back seat of that
[ __ ] yeah don't know field should be oh
yeah if you need a rat
no you need a rat can you put me in that
yeah
put me in that trunk you feel me
what i'm saying is this mama i think you
could drive anywhere you want i'll let
you drive around my neighborhood and and
you could have all types of animals in
your vehicle
um
but i think yeah animals have just a
right to see america as everybody else
[Laughter]
no matter who you are black white
spotted you know
otter hound whatever man aviary
everybody has uh equal opportunity man
native american that girl needs to be
safe going across the nation solo with
that weak ass dog yeah she's like a
german shepherd yeah if it was like are
you trying to get killed girl yeah they
just caught a serial killer the other
day
she should take the president's old
shepherd they just got rid of their dog
oh uh they have a new one named command
or some [ __ ]
biden thought it was a [ __ ] werewolf
she was buying that girl's that girl's
dope though
what's she doing traveling by herself
that's what i'm saying girl you're a
security girl
y'all sound like some damn rapist bro
you want to be in her trunk what are you
talking about you want to be in a church
station get rhino nine thousands yeah
but he would already have it in the
trunk you know girl you tired there's a
rhino nine thousand
i think they only make it 8 700.
and the lozenges are getting so big you
can't even get them down your throat
you're like damn i might as well i can't
that's what she can't even do this
listen it's christmas week and draftking
sportsbook the official sports betting
partner of the nba has a gift that will
certainly put you in a great holiday
spirit new customers can bet just five
dollars on any nba team to win 150 in
free bets if they're victorious it's a
great way to put in some extra jingle in
your pocket if sportsbook isn't
available in your state yet your
christmas can still be merry everyone
can play for huge cash prizes with
draftkings daily fantasy basketball
contest draftkings is giving all new
customers a free shot at millions of
dollars in total prizes with their first
deposit download the draftking
sportsbook app right now use promo code
cats bet just five dollars on any nba
team and win 150 dollars in free bets if
they win that's promo code kats this
christmas week at draftkings sportsbook
the official sports band partner of the
nba must be 21 or older new jersey
indiana pennsylvania only new customers
only minimum five dollar deposit one
dollar wager required one per customer
restriction supply see draftkings.com
sportsbook for details gambling problem
call 100 gambler
what's this guy want nick uh hopefully
she stays safe uh brendan asked for
people to send in some of their worst
gifts and we got a couple good ones and
then if anybody else in here remembers
their worst gift
dang
all right worst present i ever got was
also the best present i ever got i got
my bike back left my bike out
a few too many times dad said it's gonna
get stolen
it got stolen
six eight months later
showed up under the christmas tree
stole my bike
but then gave it back
it sounds like your dad took the fire
that's how you're doing
you know your dad is cheap and broke
you're the cheapest down in the world
hit your bike for six months steal this
bike yeah i'll bring it back out around
christmas he'll be stoked i don't no
what he did was he had to pawn it to pay
to pay some bills yeah that he got the
money and re-bought it back from the
pawn shop
teaching him a lesson yeah yeah terrible
yeah i remember when i was like 31 my my
grandma gave me a blanket with an eagle
on it the [ __ ] awful gift awful gift
damn brother sound like a nice gift
i had a bald eagle on it it was like a
smaller blanket i was 30 bro
yeah it sounds real nice would you get
over 40 all your gifts are going to be
[ __ ] yeah i didn't ask for gifts no more
yeah people give you a shaving cream
yeah yeah people give you a hug
yeah people get when you get over 40
they start giving you stuff that they
think you need so you get like nose hair
clippers
you know what i mean
you get yeah yeah you get some stuff
like yeah there's some new deodorant i
think that you uh i hate when they give
me cologne like i don't like this
[ __ ] rachel gives me candles all the
time she was giving me candles
yeah but for like christmas yeah that's
a [ __ ] crisp you know what i'm saying
like i mean i opened it had the nerve to
wrap it too so i'm open it up like oh
it's a candle oh thank you for your best
with your your bed
what's that what's the best gift y'all
got i remember my dad got me remember my
my pet monster and at the time those
things were hype you couldn't get them
anywhere my dad found out toys r us
somebody returned it
and my dad told me they're all sold out
we can't do anything and then my pet
monster showed up to bro i was so
[ __ ] crunk i slept with that monster
wrestled with them
played video games with them put them on
the back of my bike my best yes with the
chains on it oh wow then they had a
cartoon of it oh my god i loved him that
was my best friend as a kid all right s
m explain what you want to yeah
explains a lot that's why you were sexy
that's my best friend same nose as theo
you a sexual deviant because of this
threat the same nose as steel now theo's
my best friend
you know
we could have some relation i also got a
teddy rubskin i was also [ __ ] hyped
about that remember teddy robskin oh
yeah
you put you put the cassette in the back
and he talks to you tells you stories ah
you were a little
little baby baby you were like yeah what
you was yeah yeah oh i'm sorry my
parents love me oh here we go i got a
saw one time i got a saw
you got tools
we got a battery charger one time hey
here's the thing about teddy ruxin that
that jaw that moves that [ __ ] is pretty
fragile his jaw fell off and it was
[ __ ] terrifying well that sounds like
you a sexual deal that's what i'm saying
he was trying to put his dick in it you
know what i mean
he just fell off he's talking teddy he
keep talking ted keep talking that [ __ ]
he kind of hold it all fell off yes jaw
fell off man i was terrified of that
thing the safe word was lamb chop
[Laughter]
and then my brother got remember this
this is old school my brother got a 3do
do you remember 3dos it was there's like
sega nintendo then there's 3do man
uh brendan where would you add
you know what rambo were you living in i
think i had one of those too for a
second yeah
panasonic yeah but y'all don't know i
had a coleco vision though i think i got
that for christmas
wow
yeah those were the days
he was pretty quiet it didn't sound like
he had many good christmases
i don't remember what we had man i
remember we got
one time we didn't have much man we got
a dang i remember mom gave us each a big
two-liter soda when i was young
but she wrapped everybody got a treat
was it rhubarb
no i got a diet cherry seven up makes
sense thicker kid um but did she did you
guys wear the christmas tree or did she
put it outside at the tree outside was
that the christmas tree or like did you
have christmas trees
yeah we did we had an indoor tree
my mom wants to decorate a palm tree we
always had a fake tree when i was a kid
and i had to put it together yeah [ __ ]
yeah she has real trees man that's a
nightmare who makes their kid put
together a fake tree for me
and i had like christmas lights i don't
know how they got tangled every single
year nightmare if one was loose they all
didn't work yeah so it was like but i
remember putting the tree together it
was like a lot that was like my
christmas was me doing that because my
mom was working and stuff a lot i was by
myself a lot
it sounds like you need a my pet monster
doug yeah maybe yeah i would have [ __ ]
it
i would have humped it yeah they're all
we're all talking about the gifts we
received but this person uh wants us
wants to let us know the best gift
they've ever given i feel like nick got
some shitty gifts as a kid i don't know
really i always got pretty i got like
one that one nice thing yeah one night
it was my thing was always there's
always one nice thing
a video game or something i remember
that yeah i got a computer one year from
my big brother from big brothers of
america rich rich i know it was like the
first it was brothers big brothers yeah
that was about another big sister thing
yeah yeah i had a big brother from big
brothers of america was your brother's
like seven he's a cool dude i still he's
i still keep in contact with him oh damn
you call him big bro no i call him david
i call big bro man and um he got me uh
it was like a apple 2c it was like the
first computer i ever had wow he
actually got me two because i got i got
a commodore 64 from him the [ __ ] that
oh that's calculated you got a
calculator no it's computer it was the
first computer it was the first vic-20
64. what did he look like yeah the white
guy
white guy jewish
oh yeah man my stepmom dude my stepmom
did that big brother big sister thing
and she got some vato girl from [ __ ]
inner city denver and this [ __ ] kid
come over it was a nightmare
yeah nightmare really i i had a big
brother and uh had him from like second
grade and i wanted someone who was like
athletic like football and [ __ ] and i
got this like nerdy engineer guy who's
really cool he was the man
and i like once i got was going into
seventh grade i just like told my
grandma i didn't want to go anymore and
i wouldn't answer his phone calls oh wow
you ghosted him i gotta like reach out
it's like one of my deepest regrets oh
man oh my my word only [ __ ] god damn
that you son of a [ __ ] yeah that poor
guy signed up to take you on
all that stuff and you [ __ ]
cold-shouldered this [ __ ] guy he
probably hates children now god because
of you before they he ghosted him they
did a thing on the local news where they
came and they're like this little boy
wants a big brother damn you're on the
news yeah looking all sad yeah they're
like what are you like you mean they had
you in the noodle they do dogs like
please somebody come adopt this german
shepherd
and they were there all day and then
there was like 30 seconds they just
looked like a little [ __ ] and then i
got it
you blocked him i remember my big
brother uh he the one thing like i was
like i was only seven or eight and he
took me to see a scary movie hell yeah
no but it was a double feature i'll
never forget it because one movie we saw
phantasm
and
um
it was phantasm and the fog yeah was
this in the 60s
i will slap you
[Laughter]
the phantasm was a scary [ __ ] movie
it had this silver ball was flying
through the sky and it would like uh it
would it would like
attach onto people's forehead and it
would drill holes in their forehead and
like blood would be everywhere and i
just was like i freaked out and i
started crying and he had to take me out
of the theater and i think at the time
he thought oh you could take it you know
you know we're going to go see a scary
movie but he was like he's not a dad so
right now
oh [ __ ] i should have done that and that
freaked the hell out of me man i saw
like but i still i love scary movies now
that didn't like scar me where i was
like i can never watch a scary movie but
like we saw it was a double feature the
fog
and uh this the fog was this a driver
driving eric so old the wet different
weather was uh scary precipitation
he went and saw precipitation too
wind oh have you seen wind bros [ __ ]
that's a hero
sprinkling they redid the they you went
to the original one
sprinkling yeah
damn bro you heard they're playing hell
over there at the new uh at the new
cinema 7.
hey at least i had movie theaters where
i grew up these poor guys big brothers
big sisters man
we would have to have somebody come back
to the neighborhood and just tell us
what happened at the time
were like you had to like have a white
wall and like a light and they would
they would do fingers you know and then
the monster would come
that's how you saw it and they would sit
and watch be like
oh
a bird came
that was theo's movies what's this guy
one nick uh so we got one more before
you do the gift exchange this person
wanted to let us know the best gift
they've ever given
very special submission brendan theo
eric and stevie and anyone else
listening to this
this is santa and i've been asked by
many people what's the best gift i've
ever given anyone well here's the answer
first of all it's an unusual gift i do
not give many of them away each year
most children if you think about it are
takers
there are very few children that are
givers yeah the greedy little what i
have here is the giver bell
now let me explain to you what a giver
child is oh good grief that's a child
who writes me a letter or comes to see
me in locations where i'm at
and says santa i really don't need
anything this year i have everything i
want
what i'd like you to do is i'd like you
to help out my cousin or my grandmother
or my friend
who's had hard times
and whatever you want to give me give it
to them because they need it more than i
do
that's a giver child many parents don't
realize they have a giver child only 40
more seconds
and when i come this is what theo's dad
looked like when he was born
i explained to them why i'm doing it
then i bring the parents in
and i explain to the parent nick what
are we doing here
i'll tell you right now i don't trust
this guy man i don't trust any grown man
who gets too into santa grows the beard
out once a year i don't trust those
small santas man i've tried look i've
met this santa and i know this man and
he's a good santa
and uh but that's a long video
it was a long video
and they watched
the weather outside it's frightful god
that
it's an entertainment show for [ __ ]
sakes
wrap it up dude yeah i thought he was
going to bring out like an ethiopian kid
and be like this is umbaku he needs
you know just get let's give him some
stuff that's that was a lot yeah when we
get it though we get what you're saying
it's best to give yeah but also [ __ ]
that sound yeah but it was also like he
was also like kids or selfish little
[ __ ] sam yeah no [ __ ]
when he gets there he's like yeah i want
to [ __ ] yeah what am i supposed to do
it's a kid dude what do you mean
you make kids feel guilty also do they
have to sit on your lap your [ __ ]
pedophile i don't think they don't even
doing that anymore they are dude that my
son just went to when the santa had a
[ __ ] like mask on oh that's weird
but you're literally your little bruiser
probably was going to kick him into you
know i hope he would i hope he would
kick them in the belly i don't i don't
trust those small santas think about it
man and if you're in the nashville area
and you want to book this santa just go
to santa at santa clause.org yeah if you
want him to read your kid a bedtime
story so he falls asleep booked this
[ __ ] santa yeah he should have cut
you us wrong
all right well we should have just had
him send in a one minute video but
look what what is he trying to get
across there nick that man the best gift
he's ever given is his giver bell to
children who aren't greedy [ __ ] and
complain about their gifts boring
he he wants to show that uh giving's
good and yeah i didn't have the heart to
make him do it again and make it a
minute he was like i'm 73 and it's 9 p.m
oh yeah he was yeah he's like listen
dude i've had 10 [ __ ] whiskey [ __ ]
eggnogs man i'm trying my best here yeah
i guess christmas gift exchange dice
game all right can you play some white
elephant
white elephant it up dude
what does this mean
what is what
everybody brought
sounds a little
yeah do we have to say white elephant
can't just be an elephant these days
good point or a brown elephant okay i'll
color elephant we should all grab a gift
okay and then from there we'll i guess i
didn't read the email i'm so sorry
this wasn't in it this wasn't it but
this is how you play the game it's very
simple we'll all grab one off the table
and then there's exchanging based on
what we roll three years let me just
bring up something you want me to roll
first i get some money on my wallet
yeah money works
everyone grabs a gift
oh you're grabbing oh i hope this is a
calendar of theo is this a gift yeah
i'll grab this oh
okay well i'll take that one
[Laughter]
still have something did you send
something there for thea
i have one there nick's gonna open it up
on my behalf for chenwell one of these
guys
and mine i think hopefully is cocaine
[Laughter]
don't you have enough
don't you got a local guy
they don't make enough brother can never
have enough i'm going to take this one
and bring a gift did everybody got one
oh you didn't bring one i forgot to
bring it oh gosh
well look i'll sacrifice mine nick and
you guys can just play there and i'll
just be supportive from here all right
yeah yeah theo's the giver bell give
theo
yeah i'll i'll be the giver bill i got
riley mao here with me anyway in the
studio over here today so phil also has
that hawaii hat
yeah
all right we'll just look at people in
here it'll make it easy that makes sense
see it works out all right you want me
to roll the dice uh yeah yeah
four what is that everyone pass to the
left
oh i get this little [ __ ] one
and you guys can just keep the dice over
there and roll for us go ahead
now
five
what is that unwrap your gift
that was quick that's fun all right that
makes that's it
that's it no no no no the person who
rolled it oh okay so you whoever rolled
it would you give brendan that's your
gift eric no eric unwrapped so i'd wrap
this yeah but someone could still steal
it just because this is a gift card
to amc yeah and there's a something
oh
and that's it you can get popcorn that's
all
i am almost positive that gift card is
the one i gave for white elephant last
year no it's actually from our old
school mj mj
also it probably doesn't work no it does
what is the total 25 yeah 25.
it does work that 10 bonus work baby
right there
chin you're making you we
bringing you in the studio four
four pounds against the left no i'm
rolling now uh i'm michael
i got a four passes left
sometimes i remember mom would play a
song and that would be this is your gift
listen to this you know this is this
journey song kids
yeah it wasn't even it wasn't yeah
it was like take me home
you want me to you might wrong
as you want
four we're going to now make open your
gift because the passing is
too much so four or five and yeah yeah
put that santa back on this [ __ ] is
killing me
that's how bad it is
uh five unwrap your guests unwrap your
game so this is it yeah or did i get my
put mine smells like dog food man
oh my god dude
put old giver belle wilson back on there
man this thing i got blind fire i don't
have a dpd player
blind fire that's a condom flavor isn't
it holiday nog non-alcoholic boring
nobody wants this one
brendon would not give the giver bell
some ufc uh trading cards
open it up
some rhino 9000 oh this is that really
what that was no it's hand sanitizer
and some lit ass cookies
oh cookies are nice yeah that's nice
somebody rob a target
is that what this one is yeah brandon or
eric
all right i'm rolling yeah that looks
like a lost in fact
[Laughter]
six make two people swap gifts
my [ __ ] kid
yeah y'all got to go see spiderman
that's really good uh your turn there's
also sing two out
which oh that's i liked seeing one me
too yeah that was good unwrap your gift
all right let's just call it here what's
in here
should we just call it here because i
can't think all right cool perfect
everybody open their gift
all right my favorite gift is a giveaway
for somebody too my my favorite gift are
the kids you don't ask for [ __ ]
i got a book yeah you got a military
book man
for everything that's also made out to
joe rogan too so that's a special book
is intended for joe rogan but they send
it to me oh really yeah
yeah read the thing oh for joe rogan
thanks for always supporting our veteran
tribe and always here you go eric it's a
great
[Laughter]
i couldn't see it was blocked by eric's
arm and there was like oh no that's for
my shoes i'm wearing but this is the
book this is the gift
that's it so you got a shoe bag and a
book yeah so you took the good gift you
took the shoes
out all right i got this one was from
theo
what is it okay
jeremiah watkins uh family union special
the vinyl the vinyl
oh that's gonna be a collector's item
it is
stevie missed out man
you betcha man merry christmas to you
oh do you open the deals oh that's this
one oh yes there's one there that one oh
open that one right in front of the
field right there please chen
oh it is it was an amazon box i saw that
yeah yeah i just wanted to hide it you
might have to really rip it out of there
yeah
yeah just get
it'll be a
great gift it was a picture of your big
brother
[Laughter]
me and jack yeah
yeah
damn kyle aggressive with a dog what if
it's glass oh my god turn the santa
video on
there's editing good grief well that
santa was not having it huh come on put
put some strength into it man
this is a child i can't even read or
write i know
yeah that's dana was like you know how
kids are full of [ __ ] man
nice guy
my favorite child i've ever seen
that santa needs to get on that call map
so you can put people to sleep
in the mic
uh it is the wire complete fourth season
hey these are the worst [ __ ] kids of
all time no he went today because he
went to the walmart bin hey the wired
24th season on dvd if he gets kids and
just that's only disc two episodes four
through seven
and then the west wing
yep six season complete so if you missed
the first five then you get the six
another classic and then dude this is
super special what makes marriage last
40 celebrated couples share with us the
secrets to happy life by phil donahue
yes
who's been divorced three times
phil donnie well he got the secret
you've been married zero so read it
you're right dude yeah i am oh for oh
um i'll say this man phil doc
go on this is insane
he's with some young chick with botox on
the front
brandon wants it yeah bro these are the
worst gifts ever
yeah
what do you mean brendan these are good
gifts let me just go to a random page
i'm [ __ ] psyched about west wing the
sixth season i've never seen the first
five
president bartlett did
and now you don't have to see the first
five dude dude or the wire the complete
fourth season before it's only episodes
four through seven
what yeah that was the season when they
were at the school with all the children
oh yeah well that's those one through
three though so you know what the [ __ ]
happening
you'll be fine
you'll figure it out yeah yeah dude
yeah this is weird she'll be fine
brendan just put one of them on and
quiet down
uh that's it
that's it i think that's it well happy
holidays deal have a great christmas
brother in uh louisiana yep youtube eric
chen
merry christmas everybody
hugs to all of you you know kyle yeah
what a
what a year man it's been a long year
and thank you guys uh for uh
including me and putting me at putting
up with me when i'm in and out of town
man thank you very much and i love you
guys and merry christmas we got riley
mao here too i don't know if is there a
camera on you riley or not no
kitty can he oh there is no you want to
bring him over by you
just huh if you can't if you're only
listing us on audio think he looks like
chan if chin was 13. 13 or 12 oh welcome
back buddy
is that to get away from theo
oh should we facetime stevie he's like i
gotta oh we don't blame him well i don't
know if stevie's gonna have it you know
he doesn't seem happy i want to see that
eye yeah i want to see that you know
tell him to open it though so we can
really get him in so we should really
get a look at it you know i don't think
he's going to do it nick you is not
happy yeah you know it's like
the asian eye is uncircumcised that's
what it is
all right kiddos i'm in dania florida
and the year the right way bringing the
new year the right way dania florida
fort lauderdale florida december 30th
january 1st to see i'm in raleigh north
carolina in january get your tickets
baby baby
yep i'll be february 2nd in jacksonville
uh i'm in st petersburg then and then
orlando and then um
the 24th i'm in lafayette indiana
rockford illinois chicago illinois uh
tulsa and los angeles uh theovon.com
tour thank you guys so much and merry
christmas to everybody that's out there
that that enjoys christmas and holiday
time yeah me too i don't know i got
stuff coming out but whatever
next episode we'll talk about it
so i got we got to talk about these
bonuses brennan call me man yeah what's
up hey dog what's up with these bonuses
yet
that santa that [ __ ] bored us to
death wasn't cheap
christmas bonus for everybody love you
guys bye bye god bless everyone everyone
god bless us everyone
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
stevie weeby used to wrestle down at paw
way tonight only finished boys in the
hallway this ain't the greatest show on
earth and what you call that eric
griffin with them he the nate dogger
podcast
get a whole crew sick it's the king in
the state what up chin what up nick
stevie weeby eric griffin just walked in
and got it lit you can't forget about
brendan he still need everything dick
dick they still got the bees and the
trap trapping still the king and the
stinks who quit asking if you know then
you know it's a cat's thing ball and
chain hair swang like the rat king king
and the stink
back with the crew we got stevie weeby
eric griffin brendan theo too yeah you
know how we do it so just tune in for
the laughs theo said that he was on his
way but ran out of gas
[Music]
[Applause]
king and the sting
you